but you know what when you were talking
I was thinking you see shows now like
fresh off the bone Ken shell mm-hmm that
doesn't that's to me not my experience
there isn't a show that shows like
because the Asians I hang out with mmm
these ones I have hundreds of other ones
David chose a good friend my brother's
one you know and we were more this
mm-hmm
you are experiences yeah we need to get
something on the air yeah that shows
that no I would think that you know it
should have I mean it should have
happened by now but we should do it I
mean there's definitely a rebellious
streak in people like yourself and me
and and of course David and we don't see
that yet yeah you know somebody that's
just really you have to be such a rebel
to do to break out of the culture that
we come from yeah you know and even even
David like I saw his documentary I was
shocked at how much deference he had for
his family and how much of a sort of a
church boy like him oxide newsboy yeah
yes - yeah but and to be so incredibly
bold and driven and different and and
really irreverent as he is yeah but
that's been my experiences with Koreans
though maybe you know I just have a
specific kind of experience because I'm
in show business or whatnot and these
are the kind of Koreans I meet but
generally even before I did comedy the
minorities that would me were more my
type we so you're saying they we're the
jungle Asians but I want to say
something right now and this really made
me mad okay lean forward yeah yeah we
I've been close to you before yeah yeah
it is Thursday I was reading for
auditioning for a movie it was a stoner
movie okay it was five lines okay okay
and of course I'm gonna read for that
movie because um I'm really got nothing
coconut really right I mean I you know I
people know I am but on the cost and um
and I I want to work and you know so I'm
sitting there with these five lines and
they're okay lines and a kid walks in
who's auditioning for the same part it
was Steven Yeun now mmm
I looked at him and I go after your
audition I'm gonna yell at you outside
uh-huh so I took Steven you're not that
I didn't yell at him but I went how do
you not get an offer I know that's crazy
yeah he's in the show right now he's a
troll so he's I love him too right and
he goes dude I got a read yeah we all
have to read yeah but if that was a
white dude yeah yeah let's be real they
would no he would not have to deal with
that kind of [ __ ] he would not have to
read for five lines no it's true it
would've been an offer why he wants to
do this movie five lines yeah
offer 12 yeah yeah but he had a sign-up
wait in line and I find it to be [ __ ]
crazy it's crazy it's crazy you know
it's like I can understand if it was
just if it was me yeah I mean I had a
point where I was hot ten twelve years
ago you know I do the road I draw it's
fine I know where I meant I'm not
complaining I love where I'm at I have a
great part because I have you Margaret's
here I love my life but I know where I'm
at in terms of your real like movies and
showbiz and all that stuff right him I
love him and he's a culture but he's
like that guy from Breaking Bad what's
his name Aaron Aaron Paul Breaking Bad
exactly dan movies lead in a TV show
they come out the same level about the
same thing about this yeah yeah yeah I
guarantee you right now that Aaron Paul
would not audition for five lines they
have a Hamilton of course not of course
they would hand him and I mean it's you
know to not think of this as a racist
business it's just it's of course it is
it is and the truth is is that you know
we have to read we have to go in for
things and it's shocking yeah it's
shocking especially for somebody like
him yeah I thought believe that I can't
believe it if you guys have to read I
mean [ __ ] makes me look like my Pat's
almost impossible you never know I don't
think I am you guys are yeah yeah I'm
there I mean no I want you to keep going
this kid right here we luckily found him
but he is so talented he's from second
city in Chicago and he's very talented
but [ __ ] hard enough you guys are it
well it's also you know but it's also
that there are fewer roles for Asian
Americans that that's the other part of
it too and so you're constantly battling
people's ideas of what we can do you
know and it's it's like we have to try
to expand it that's why it's always
better to just write your own projects
and create your own work and just do
stand-up comedy and do different things
it's it's hard it's really hard here's
another thing that pisses me off about
autism what in the you know how you get
you get so anyone listening when you get
an audition you get a sheet it says
where it is at who the director is all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] but there's always
sometimes every once in a while there's
like a little specific note for you for
me so attention Bobby no accent well has
it see you I don't know but they were
tell it's I this audition wasn't for an
Asian guy so they had to specifically
tell me that I don't have to do an
accent as if I was gonna come in there
go ahead you know they had to
specifically give me an O that seems
racist to me you hate doing accent I
know it's pretty right system but to
read it on the thing and specifically
say no accent crazy made me think that
they thought that I was gonna go in
there and just like get E one knob yet
you know I love getting one I do too I
love I actually I don't know why you
said that no no because of the legacy of
long Duk dong yeah
that's why the thing about it is he's
really funny I love him
I think he's great he's a nice guy till
he's a really nice guy but the the fact
is that if we're not given roles that
are worthy of us we are constantly
having to sort of wade through and do
whatever we can when and then when there
is a role that's supposed to be for an
Asian person they change it to a white
person mm-hmm
you know they did that with 21 oh you
tell this one yeah she got the stranger
she contacted me mrs. Wong you know Alex
yeah Alex Borstein yeah Alex Borstein
she hooked us up right anyone knows was
on that she's not she's a white girl
Yeah right so she does it to me this one
was hilarious yes so she said is it cool
if I give tilda your number because she
wants to talk to you
Oh Mike can I go all right
[Music]
well till the email and eventually
emailed me and um she said that she
didn't understand why people were so mad
about dr. strange and she wanted to talk
about it you know and I wanted to get my
take on why all the Asian people weren't
mad and do you know long conversation
and it was so weird you know and I was
like you know she could you please tell
them not to be so I'm like but I can't
tell who are the president of all agents
where you are you are American division
yeah I don't have a yellow phone under a
kid
oh yeah we should don't have that there
should be a lucky yellow phone
representing partnership with a barber
town
yeah I'm nominating her nominating yes
do it I think everyone was hands down
you're the person should we call Kate we
had a long discussion and she also
wanted me not to tell anybody so don't
tell anybody and then I you know but it
was a long like kind of a fight about
why the part should not have gone to her
that's what I thought yeah it should not
have gone to her and we in fight about
it and and basically it ended with her
saying well I'm producing a movie with
Steven Yeun is starring oh I have a
black right I could see I can do this
I'm paying my dues for your for the
Asian so therefore I can be then I also
have to read for it yeah yeah it was
weird because it was like I felt like
you know one of not like it like a house
Asian like I'm like her servant you know
like the one like the ones like when
they have like a you know like whatever
in the Raj or whatever they would have
liked the house servant yeah sort of
you're confident
yeah well those merchants I every movies
and stuff India there was always like
the sort of servant that was close to
you yeah what I felt like like I was
following her with an umbrella I had a
weird feeling about the entire exchange
especially the party don't tell anybody
it's also this as when you told me about
that we didn't get into a deep
discussion about it but you mentioned it
and I go oh they're friends yeah but now
it's not that
you didn't know I just admitted
assumption that you guys knew each other
no I didn't know her in fact only knew
her from Alex
well mrs. Swan the reason why I got mad
TV was because mrs. Swan was leaving so
they were like we need you know maybe
try nation a real agent this might sound
crazy but bring a real agent so four
months into me doing um being on the
show which is terrible when I was first
on it was terrible but I get a call from
Fox and they said can you do miss one
play that and I go no I will not for
number one I can't and number two I
won't do that and they were like why not
because it's not my character yeah and
also that's not what I do right right
but just the idea that they were like
you know he's Asian
you mean and we own the rights to the
character yeah it's like do you sit with
all of this you know lack of roles for
Asians do you sit idly by or do you get
loud and angry like what is the right
what is read the recourse for like at
this point you I mean there's only a
handful if you really think about it of
people or voices for the Asian community
that are going to really say it out loud
or a bold enough to say it out loud and
you always worry about how is that going
to affect your career in the long run
because you don't think that you know
being angry is the right route well I
know that's Steven Park wrote a mission
statement did you ever read it you know
Steven Park yeah yeah apparently he
wrote a mission statement and sent a
letter out to agents and producers and
whatnot about the plight of the Asian
actor and he was thrown out ala that
when he moved to New York yeah I mean
with what's-her-name his wife she's
great
girl she was on in living color too that
white chick anyway yet kids with her but
he left LA for years
he came back mm-hmm but I that's why I
haven't been vocal because when I found
out that he got thrown out like he
couldn't get auditions that's crazy yeah
that I was afraid to say anything you
know now that I'm not working really
that much about being funny about it too
which is so great yeah you take it and
talk about it you're standing I do yeah
you're really funny yeah that's the
right I think course of action because
you could just make it part of your work
that's hilarious and then also it gets
the point across also I'm not that angry
mm-hmm here's my my point of view is
that I am it it hurts a little bit you
know it's it's racism I think it's
racism but because I've made a living
maybe it has I haven't felt the real you
know I feel more bad for younger Asian
kids right that you know me want to make
a name for themselves and it's just
harder but I felt like I've did a couple
of hurdles over it you know Margaret
first sent them up she jumped over I
jumped over a cup all right and I feel
like it's getting a little better
even though all these things are
happening yeah you still have Steven
Yeun you still have fresh off the boat
is a popular show it's a network show
Randall's a great guy Ken it's an Asian
show so these are things that are
obviously new so I guess in that way I'm
not yes over it and it's getting better
and certainly what's great is that we
have stand-up comedy which is the best
because you can do whatever you want
and it's incredibly gratifying you make
a good living and I'm just really
pleased that I started off doing comedy
you know that's that's the best that's
the [ __ ] [ __ ] right there that was
better yeah I just I wanna [ __ ] in
the [ __ ]
[Music]